welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
loki episode one in which the god of
mischief learns he's just one infinity
stone in a big box from the many mcu
callbacks to a cartoon i hope you're all
taking notes during there is so much to
unpack so i'm gonna break this down shot
by shot for all the cool details that
you might have missed we open on new
york city 2012 the scene of loki's
escape when we last saw him in avengers
end game actually this shot is the same
exact establishing shot used an end game
but with the portal bean the chitari and
a few explosions removed now that the
battle's over and listen to this four
note chime the episode opens with
[Music]
yeah this is directly from the end game
score when tony snuck back into the
tower
notice how the letters flicker in
folding down from the middle just like
the split flap display on old train
station signs matching the overall
analog production design of the tva as
if they're flipping back to the state
and this prologue now mixes in alternate
takes from chris evans during loki's
in-game arrest on my way down coordinate
search and rescue on my way down to
coordinate search and rescue on my way
down to coordinate search and rescue on
my way down to coordinate search and
rescue yeah notice how in this new take
loki's cap impression is more robotic
and less of these or yes sir it was an
in-game it's just an example of how we
are already seeing variations to what we
saw before and although it's not focused
on they kept in ant-man he's still
barely visible running up tony's arm as
he closes the suitcase so then
downstairs as the fumble tesseract
slides to loki's feet listen to its
sound
and now it's a much fuller coral chime
compared to the sound we heard in
endgame
showing how for loki this tesseract is
still a sacred key to the god king
status that he seeks but later on as he
realizes this infinity stone is
literally one of an infinite amount of
these rocks that precious hum fades away
but not knowing that yet loki zips away
with the space stone leaving thor's
voice calling out in the void where's
loki
audio also taken from in-game in the
background where's loki loki miss panic
tells us that loki just created a
disrupted history displacing himself
from his destined historical path of
accompanying thor back to asgard as he's
supposed to this is why loki is a
variant in violation of the tva's sacred
timeline by teleporting with the space
stone he didn't go back in time or enter
any new reality but he did warp this
history causing it all to branch off
from the sacred timeline now of course
the avengers also created branch
timelines by taking each stone but when
cap returned those stones those branches
were erased however cap returning the
tesseract to 1970 would not have erased
loki's theft in 2012 leaving him as the
one lingering paradox that the tva is
super pissed off about then the marvel
studios title turns green with a flash
of gold of course the colors of loki
then we find ourselves in mongolia's
gobi desert this cool shot of an insect
crawling reflected upside down in a
droplet of water recalling this loki's
recent arrogance an ant has no quarrel
with a boot of course threw back in his
face later in that movie and
boot and now this pompous god is about
to get stomped back down to earth as an
insect compared to the might of the tva
and in this shot the camera pushes in on
loki's crash landing in the sand
recalling the shot of iron man's crash
landing in the first iron man film a
similar tale of an egomaniac forced to
reconcile with his actions transitioning
from a violent villain to just a
mischievous hero since remember this is
the 2012 era loki not the nicer guy that
he evolved to be in the later films
though this episode does kind of get him
close to it via dramatic home movies but
yes the tva time variants authority
these are the marvel time cops they
prosecute timeline violators with an
army of minutemen foot soldiers chrono
monitors and judges representing them
now is hunter b15 her scanner labels
loki as variant l-1130 and notice how
the units drop from five towards zero
meaning their whole sacred timeline is
always just five whatever these units
are away from branches veering into
redline territory showing how delicate
this timeline really is the tva's
weapons are these glowing batons which
could be handheld versions of the
retroactive cannon that the tva uses in
the comics to erase people from
existence aka retcon notice how b15s
glows violet unlike the others that glow
orange as we see later orange is a color
used to reset violators to their native
timeline so maybe violet is a setting
used to stun a violator in amazing slow
motion
you're now moving at 1 16th speed but
feeling all that pain in real time
yikes she is forcing loki to feel all
this pain but dilated out 16 times
longer than he should punishment via
time dilation is actually a recurring
theme on the show black mirror in which
actress wounmi masaku who plays hunter
b15 previously tortured wyatt russell's
character in a time dilated hell so they
end up pruning this timeline with a
reset charge that begins orange and then
turns purple now previously purple
sorcery has been associated with agatha
harkness before that dormammu in the
dark dimension and in doctor strange
remember timeline reversal like this was
considered a form of dark magic loki
creator michael waldron wrote the latest
draft of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and in an
interview with mt he teased that he may
have been smart enough to include these
links between the two titles did you set
up anything in loki episodes that you
could cash in later on in doctor strange
to the multiverse of madness or call
back anything in doctor strange from
loki i think that's something you you'll
have to you have to watch it all and
find out fi find find out if i was that
smart or not and we'll talk about more
of these later so we arrive at the tva
with interiors that are often colored
with eye scorching orange this color was
often used in early 70s designs to come
off as warm and inviting but now just
come off as cringey and uncomfortable
and tortuous much like the orange miss
minutes there's no another variant is a
skrull wearing a tracksuit squirrel's of
course the shape-shifting race seen in
captain marvel's fight rampart from home
one division squirrels are just gonna
start showing up everywhere as we head
towards secret invasion p15 rewinds loki
back to her with a device later called
the time twister now in the comics the
time twisters are actually beings
created by accident during the creation
of the time keepers they move backward
in time and destroy all in their path
here the device is a remote leash to
whomever is wearing the collar comedian
josh fado plays variant named martin my
dad is on the board of goldman sachs one
with a name like martin i gotta wonder
if he could be based on martin shkreli
but either way how did this rich brat
from earth end up as a timeline variant
could this be jimmy woo's witness in
federal witness protection who went
missing with no explanation are we ever
gonna get an answer to that i don't know
and then comedian eugene cordero plays
tva clerk named casey notices pins in
his front pocket later in the episode
the ink will leak more and more into a
shirt poor guy here he takes the
tesseract can you at least tell me what
it is it's the tesseract be very careful
with it sounds dumb yeah casey thinks
the tesseract is dumb because he has a
ton of confiscated space stones and none
of them stored a stupid tesseract also
maybe casey knows a tesseract is
technically a fourth dimensional
hypercube incapable of being seen by
human 3d perception but he doesn't know
what a fish is i love it loki meets this
pervy d clothing bot who greets him with
a slow warming smile that ends with the
right eye twitching a bit just a little
unnerving to have the thing stripping
you naked glitch but as we will see the
tva's clockwork is a bit glitchy in
general the transcript room features a
cat who's also on this guy's mug or is
it a flerkin also i love how this guy is
playing solitaire on his little orange
display when loki dropped in poor guy
his wall clock like all the clocks we
see in the tva features multiple hands
and more than 12 numbers around the
circumference everything loki has ever
said is printed out on this dot matrix
printer though as someone who's over a
thousand years old i would think that
stack should be way larger and then loki
gets his body scanned for his temporal
aura which prints out on polaroid film
kind of like a heat index but presumably
for time almost like instant carbon
dating and the attendant asks please
confirm to your knowledge that you are
not a fully robotic being we're born an
organic creature and do in fact possess
what many cultures would call a soul
yeah he specifies fully robotic and born
organic because we know cybernetically
reassembled beings like nebula probably
have a soul i i think but also just like
this idea that there are ultron like
robots out there that are trying to pass
as organic life forms bring up an
interesting question that loki asks do a
lot of people not know if they're robots
what if i was a robot and i didn't know
it yes some existential panic from loki
recalling the voigt camp test of blade
runner that was used to test ai
replicants who might not even know if
they're robots but i see this as one
first step by loki from godly arrogance
to mortal fear now the next room has
this poster showing miss minutes warning
behavior get your clock cleaned which is
literally what the minutemen do with
their ret cannons to reset people's
clocks actually there are great tva
posters everywhere in this place zero
tolerance over the ticket checking
window because yeah they got zero
tolerance over whether or not you got a
ticket later there's one showing a
shadowy suited figure reading always
watching you can see a better shot of it
in the credits just a big brother-y and
warning from the high ranks of the tda
another one saying stable society tidy
timeline with the dude pruning branches
and a poor bird looking at him while he
does so just an example of how the tva
doesn't really care about any worthy
life in new branch timelines that get
formed it's all about the trunk then
tidy cubicle healthy timeline with
branch variants of a clerk at his neat
desk within one redline variant standing
on his desk going nuts yeah the
propaganda prioritizes neatness over
everything else and then later on one
nexus events must be pruned but of
course we get this adorable animation
from tva mascot miss minutes voiced by
tara strong in a southern accent kind of
like mr dna explaining the science of
jurassic park oh
mr d
where did you come from from your blog
hey by the way we have a whole loki
inspired merch lineup at our merch store
newrockersmerch.com in which ms minute
shows up quite a bit in which you can
show some worship of this miss minutes
figure check it out new
rockstarsmerch.com so miss minutes
explains a new mcu history long ago
there was a vast multiversal war but
then the all-knowing time keepers
emerged bringing peace by reorganizing
the multiverse into a single timeline
this sacred timeline so according to
this the mcu used to exist as a
multiverse of timelines timelines that
ward with each other but the timekeepers
interfered with that natural state
deciding to merge all the timelines into
one sacred timeline and that everything
we have seen in the mcu so far has been
a kind of intermediary peace time see in
the comics the three time keepers named
astavanth and zorth are creations of he
who remains the final tva agent at the
end of all time to pass on lessons to
the next universal cycle but as neutral
time deities these guys are kind of
[ __ ] they at times partner with
folks like immortus aka kang the
conqueror to wage conflict with the
avengers so this tva slogan of for all
time always is at least somewhat a lie
like it hasn't been always there was a
whole other stage of the universe where
things were multiverse so this is really
a myth cooked up to inflate their
importance and actually you can see at
the bottom this was written by the time
variance authority narrative commission
proving that they have an in-house
propaganda department this whole thing
is like the big brother ministry of
truth but back to the cartoon the past
multiversal war is represented by this
interesting fuselage in deep space maybe
we're seeing the aftermath of a conflict
among the celestials because we know
from the severed head of the celestial
nowhere that some war caused that maybe
they're going to go with the comics and
say the symbiotic null decapitated him
but i think the celestials are going to
be involved with it and then we follow
some animation inspired by rocky
bullwinkle specifically the mr peabody
and sherman shorts we've all this yellow
man and a bow tie whose variants toggle
from a sea captain to this brute to a
mug to a mad scientist to a top hat guy
but notice how each incorporates his bow
tie he's still essentially the same snob
and if this does represent loki we do
later see loki in a turtleneck from
trailer footage and that top hat form
could be loki as jack the ripper maybe
another real world mystery that loki
could have been behind the way he was db
cooper and then we also see this yellow
man leading some kind of uprising and a
battle involving a race that looks a bit
like the cree meanwhile the ships on the
right look a lot like the ruins of titan
thanos's home world that we saw infinity
war so maybe this uprising is against
the titan colony of eternals that
thanos's father alars established and
then miss minutes goes on stepping off
your path created a nexus event which
left unchecked could branch off into
madness lead into another multiversal
war nexus events reminding us how one
division defined the scarlet witch as a
nexus being a character from the marvel
comics with the ability to rewrite
reality serving as a linchpin bridging
their reality with others and by saying
branch off into madness leading to
another multiversal war yeah i think
it's a strong sign that the sacred
timeline here could be doomed to unravel
leading to a repeat of the historical
cycle in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in which juan to
search for her children via the dark
hold could cause another spark between
realities and miss minutes ends with
just make sure you have your ticket and
you'll be seen by the next available
attendant yeah notice how miss minutes
is an extreme close here just a very
stern warning signaling just how
seriously they take tickets and martin
says will you get raising your voice
with me buckethead yeah i love that they
kept in fadem's little stammer on the
word raising and martin gets
horrifically reset and loki shows this
ticket like all the passengers in
indiana joins the last crusade but
before we continue this video is brought
to you by curiosity stream the
award-winning destination for
documentary series and features it's
smart tv for your smart tv curiosity
stream has thousands of streamable
documentaries and non-fiction tv shows
on topics like history nature science
food technology and travel whether you
want to explore mars or travel back to
ancient civilizations curiosity stream
adds new binge-worthy films and series
each week letting you dive into your
favorite subjects they have 35
collections of curated programs
hand-picked by experts all that content
is streaming to any device for viewing
anytime anywhere they have award-winning
exclusives and originals like the dream
the future series narrated by sigourney
weaver a dock on curiosity stream i'm
really excited to watch is the worlds of
build gay dick about the visionary
sci-fi author who pinned source material
for blade runner total recall minority
report they also have more world war ii
and space race content then you'll know
what to do with if your dad is coming
over to visit this will keep them busy
forever so do yourself a favor and sign
up for curiosity stream you'll pick up
some better fodder for conversation than
just the weather use code new rockstar
to sign up just 14.99 for the whole year
now the loki title letters flicker in
with a white glow on this black
background and at one point the o has
little horns like loki's horned crown
leading us to exxon provence france 1549
tva agent mobius owen wilson is based on
mobius mobis in the comics we also heard
the word mobius back in endgame when
tony stark figured out time travel in
the shape of a mobius strip inverted
please now some mystery killer lured in
these minutemen here to steal their
reset charge using an anachronistic item
dropped in the past in this case
kablooey gum given to a kid to say cafe
[Music]
don't worry that devil's afraid of us
yeah i'm gonna get this out of the way
no this is not mephisto the series
creators confirmed it it's really just
meant to reflect loki as a horned
ambitious god like lucifer cast out of
his heaven we get a further clue when
mobius is handed loki variant l130s rap
sheet it's all listed out here he is
loki laufen because he's actually born
son of laufey the frost giant from
juttenheim before becoming odin's ward
thus his alias of odinson his sex is
listed as fluid
so this is a huge confirmation of the
theories that we've had for over a year
now that the alternate loki that they
are chasing is in fact a female form
probably played by sophia dimartino most
likely gonna be lady loki now in the
comics lady loki isn't really an
alternate timeline loki but rather a
post-ragnarok female body intended for a
reincarnated soul of lady sith but
instead possessed by the soul of loki
now this episode did clarify that loki
has a soul but i think they're going to
be using timeline logic instead because
somehow that's simpler now in the
courtroom are murals depicting figures
with red sashes and a legal scale these
must be the tva judges and one of those
judges with his glasses and his
moustache looks kind of like a younger
stan lee other murals show tva clerks
and technicians these could be the
chrono monitors and the army of
minutemen and on the other side the
timekeepers overseeing the sacred
timeline presiding over loki's case with
the three time keeper faces looming
behind is justice ravona rinslayer
google mobatara who in the comics is
associated with kang the conqueror one
of the many reasons i have been
speculated this time traveling villain
confirmed to come up in ant-man and the
wats quantomania played by jonathan
majors might show up in this show loki
casts blame on the avengers oh believe
me you can smell the cologne of two tony
starks uh call back to ant-man making
fun of tony's scent is that axe body
spray yeah i had a can of the desk for
emergencies relax and mobius shows loki
that tva the vast grid of spires and
platforms all with numerical
designations that we see t282 this all
seems to go on forever likely the mcu's
version of the null time zone the tva
home dimension that's removed from time
and space and loki responds by saying
this place is a nightmare that's another
department now that department i'll help
you burn down
now what would these time cops care
about people's nightmares unless maybe
their power comes from another dimension
where cosmic beans like nightmare reside
nightmare being a cosmic entity in the
marvel comics a villain to dr strange
who could show up in the second doctor
strange movie but i also like the theory
that maybe when things are ret cannoned
they live on in people's subconsciouses
and that's where nightmares come from
now the elevator buttons all correspond
to some three character alphanumeric
code that don't seem to refer to
anything specific yet but i think it's
just a sign of how complex and dewy
decimal like the different floors of the
tva are though in the end credits when
these appear on the screen the code 1ej
is immediately hit with access denied so
there is some part of the tva that is
off limits now in the time theater
mobius sips adjusta a discontinued soft
drink from the late 90s similar to that
boku fruit juice that we've seen in the
trailer footage the tba might be able to
access all the food and drinks that you
can't get anymore and in this
interrogation loki explains why he
wanted to rule i would have made it easy
for them the first and most oppressive
lie ever uttered was the song of freedom
yes connecting to a speech in germany
which mobius actually shows him among
his greatest hits in the tva hollow
projector the bright lure of freedom
diminishes your life's joy in a mad
scramble for power now moebius reminds
loki about agent coulson oh yeah phil
coulson
didn't the avengers come together to
literally avenge him if you believe that
whole sacred timeline explanation this
could be another nail in the coffin of
agents of shield's canonicity since that
show assumes coulson did not really die
though don't worry if this ends with the
sacred timeline blowing up into a
multiverse one of those alternate
timelines could just be the one agent's
shield is all set in so we're still
we're still good i think notice how the
battle of new york highlights freeze on
the waitress beth that character played
by ashley johnson chrissy saver from
growing pain birthplace of ralph phoner
take a look at this
jesus christ that was a cap subplot that
was cut from that first avengers movie
or we can now look at it as a pruned
branch storyline that mobius could be
interested in and we learned loki was
real life mystery hijacker db cooper
yeah william scott was actually the name
of the pilot of that northwest orient
305 in 1971 when db cooper or someone
using that alias hijacked a flight and
jumped out of the plane with 200 000 and
stolen cash notice how here heimdall
catches loki via the bifrost leaving
some cash floating a nod to the fact
that all they ever found of db cooper
was some cash floating in the columbia
river it was all loki all along
and it was all because loki apparently
lost a bet to thor who's all in on this
just a reminder of how much of a
reckless jerk thor used to be now as
mobius helps loki up you can see the
moment look his eyes when he spots the
time twister in his pocket and notice
how his swipe is distracted by b15's
entrance slick then while loki sneaks
around another variant gets detained in
the background i gotta say looks a bit
like peggy carter doesn't it just would
be interesting because according to the
end game directors cap living his life
with peggy created a branch timeline
what the tva might now consider to be a
variant nexus violation though really
the variant perpetrator in that case
would be old steve not his poor wife so
i don't know so logie sneaks off and
finds casey who returns to tesseract and
reveals a whole evidence drawer filled
with variant infinity stones
how do you have these
oh we actually got a lot of those
some of the guys use them as paper
weights some of them so how do they get
these well maybe each variant they've
caught may have been in possession of an
infinity stone since the ancient ones
seem to suggest that only the removal of
stones could cause branches from the
sacred timeline and maybe with each
pruning the stolen stone was just
restored back to the sacred timeline
leaving this stone and the tva as a kind
of powerless carbon copy receipt of it
now in this box you can see red reality
stones green time stones purple power
stones blue space stones a couple chunky
orange soul stones though interestingly
no yellow mine stones available and then
loki picks up a time stone as if of all
these the one he would want the most is
the ability to reverse time also in this
drawer is a super rare t206 bonus wagner
baseball card a casino chip for 5 000
and some kind of military medal and then
later in the end credits you can
actually see a mine stone being used as
a paperweight i also have to wonder what
casey meant by some of the agents using
infinity stones as paperweights could
some past dva agent have snatched one of
these went into the timeline and started
wreaking havoc to become kang i'm gonna
go with that explanation kang gang for
life b15 finds loki tries to reset him
but instead erases casey's evidence cart
showing that in addition to the variants
people and things in the tba can be
rhett cannon to somewhere loki scrubs
back through frigga's death with this
interesting music plane
this amazing mournful violin melody was
composed by the loki composer natalie
holt who is clearly very talented though
i gotta mention this because it's
amazing she used to work as a backup
musician on britain's got talent and she
freaking egged simon cowell for ruining
the music industry a freaking badass
loki also more into odin i love you my
sons
yeah focusing on one of my favorite
details from thor ragnarok tom
hiddleston's reaction to odin finally
considering loki a son and finally loki
arrives at his death
[Music]
yeah the framing makes it look like
future loki is saying this to our
variant loki like the ghost of christmas
future telling him to let go of its
god-king ambitions and then notice as
the film strip runs out on the hollow
projector it reads tail one one two nine
one four i think seven one one two nine
one four loki laufey sin meaning this is
the tail end of the film reel but the
weird thing is in the close-up of the
film strip as it goes across the
projector reel it says tail one eth six
th6161eth616 loki loffison and i only
point that out because 616 is the
numerical designation of the prime
marvel universe in the comics
technically the mcu is earth19999 so
loki ends up confessing to mobius i
don't enjoy
hurting people it's part of the illusion
so loki even back in 2012 was never a
sadist he's just a mischievous scamp who
commits violence in order to gain power
he's projecting an illusion of his
fearsomeness and that is the
confirmation mobius has been wanting
with all this questioning really this is
all a voigt camp test to determine if
loki had any humanity in him and now
that mobius knows what he does he gives
loki this assignment a chance to destroy
the worst parts of himself the variant
we're hunting is
you and so the epilogue goes to an oil
field in selena oklahoma in 1858 where
hunter u-92 investigates this
interesting device
time signature is early third millennium
definitely anachronistic early third
millennium would be
now i guess do you think first
millennium is zero to your thousand
second millennium is one thousand to two
thousand so early third millennium would
be sometime between two thousand and
twenty three hundred i guess either way
it is a sign that we are looking at some
villain with access to future technology
and here is our hooded villain our evil
loki variant burning them all in
hellfire as that stained glass demon
foretold actually in that art there is a
moon which to me recalls the trailer
footage of sophia dimartino's character
in the shadow of a collapsing moon who
is she exactly we will find out now the
end credit sequence is filled with cool
visual details so many that i actually
have to break it down in a separate
video coming tomorrow but a few things i
gotta note here among some math pinned
to an office wall is an equation whose
name is partially obscured but it looks
like schrodinger's equation i'm not
certain if this is actually
schrodinger's equation quantum physics
nerds forgive me if it isn't he's one of
the early theoretical physicists who
really pioneered quantum mechanics that
loki's branch timeline logic is really
based on jordan of course famous for his
schrodinger cat thought experiment in
which an unobserved cat is both alive
and dead simultaneously essentially
saying we all kind of exist in separate
realities there's an apocalyptic event
report describing the events of the db
cooper hijacking from seattle 1971. just
interesting that the tva categorizes
that as an apocalyptic event just make
me think that they might consider it on
par with events like the destruction of
pompeii which we also will see in this
series there's also a variant diagram
showing five different variants there's
one with a circle head and then the
other heads shaped as a square a
triangle pentagon hexagon and then an x
just like the number of variants we saw
the yellow cartoon guy have and then the
credit visuals end with the faces of the
timekeepers of the courtroom punching in
specifically on the center one before
cutting to black which i have said
before does look a bit like the face of
jonathan majors who's going to play kang
and interesting that kang's lover ravana
rinslayer was framed directly in that
figure's
lips and lastly if you stick around all
the way to the end of the credits you
can hear the voice of who miss minutes
coming back thanks for visiting the tva
don't hesitate to let us know how we're
doing and after this great first episode
i think you guys are doing great another
reminder to support this channel by
checking out our great loki inspired
merch options and newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
loki thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you